so much like the carbohydrate video in
which I had a PDF that I narrated
through I'm gonna do the same thing here
with this lineweaver-burk plot example
problem so this example problem gives
you it tells you you have a particular
enzyme catalyzed reaction in which you
have these you have substrate
concentration measured in micro molar
and you have velocity measured in nano
molecules per minute which I wrote here
nano
millech per minute that's kind of ugly
sorry about that
but they give you these values here they
give you these and they expect you to
calculate the km and the v-max after
turning it into a double reciprocal plot
this um so I graphed here the velocity
versus substrate concentration and you
would expect to see a hyperbolic curve
so if you are very careful to make sure
that your your distances are pretty
accurate then you should see that you'll
you know if you use a ruler to measure
this sort of out you can you should get
a hyperbolic graph and if that's the
case then that you can turn it into a
lineweaver-burk plot example where you
can calculate the km and the v-max so
but in order to do that you need to plot
1 over V versus 1 over the substrate
concentrations have to take all these
values and invert them right so take 1
over them so I did that here so what I
got after I did that was these values
here you'll notice these values so I
have one of the substrate concentration
right which is going to be specifically
if it's 1 over the substrate
concentration measured in micro molar
this is micro molar to the negative 1 or
1 over micro molar here this is 1 over
the velocity so this is minutes per nano
molecule okay when you have those units
inverted you can then plot the double
reciprocal plot so what I did was I took
great care to to sort of plot this out
with a ruler and measure these distances
especially here on the x axis because I
didn't have graphing paper so I try to
make it I spread the the the range of
the domain from negative 1 to 1 just
because the highest x value that I have
here is 1 the lowest one is point 0 2
and
as far as the why I just went from one
to ten just to be a thorough and then I
just plotted each of the points so I'm
not going to talk too much about this
but I encourage you to pause the video
as necessary forgive me if I my
scrolling is annoying or bothersome but
let me kind of walk you through this
portion because I the lineweaver-burk
plot portion because I feel it's the
most the more important portion so if
you have I just plotted one and then
nine point one right up here alright so
this is this is my one nine point one
and then I point three three and four
right then I add point two zero and two
point nine four and then I did you know
of course I've plotted these last few
points and I had all these dots written
down first
excuse me and then what I did was I just
connected those lines connected those
dots queued me with this line so I made
sure that the line touched each and
every single one of those points I try
to get as accurate as possible so that I
can find out what the km value would be
or what the y-intercept value would be
so then I had I wanted to be as accurate
as possible in finding the values of
these two intercepts right so what I did
then was I had the x intercept somewhere
around negative point two zero right so
what I knew then is that the x intercept
is equal to negative one over the km so
I said the negative one over km equal to
the x intercept so at negative one over
km equal to negative point two zero and
then I just rearranged to solve for K M
so the km was equal to negative 1 over
negative point two which is
approximately or which is that well the
km is approximately equal to that
because I'm I can only be so accurate
without this graph paper without you
know with just a simple ruler and some
paper but I got five micro molars right
so that essentially is five times ten to
the negative six molar which up-up
earlier we mentioned that the km was
supposed to be five point two times ten
is ten to the night of six molar so
that's pretty close I mean all I had was
this paper so maybe this value slightly
a little bit little bit you know off
it's not exactly a negative point to
zero but it's pretty close and my answer
sort of you know shows that the x
intercept I said I approximated it to be
approximately one
point five so I know the v-max or C me
the the y-intercept is equal to one over
the v-max so one of the v-max will equal
one point five approximately and because
of that then the vemma actually equal
one over one point five which is 0.66
now that was nano molecules per minute I
didn't write the per minute here but
0.66 nano molecules for a minute is just
the same thing as point six six times
ten to the negative nine molecules per
minute so just and I just moved over the
decimal point to get six point six times
ten to the negative ten molecules per
minute which the answer was supposed to
be six point eight times 10 to the
negative 10 molecules per minute and of
course this is the equation for the
graph so I encourage you to sort of
practice this use a ruler try to be as
accurate as possible so that your
estimates can be can be as close to the
the right numbers as possible
I hope this this example is helpful even
though I'm not working all the way
through it I encourage you to to work
through it on your own so as to you know
test your ability to work through this
okay that's it and happy studying